in the responsive world choosing images
to suit the viewing context art
direction can be accomplished pretty
easily with the picture element to
enable display of a crop of an image or
even a different image depending on
image display size now in this example
we're using media queries to specify the
source full-sized kitten for a large
viewport medium kitten for medium
viewport and a small kitten for small
people
kid this is doing art direction choosing
a different image with just a few lines
of HTML okay hold on to your hat here's
the full monty we've combined media
queries and source set to specify images
for smaller and larger viewports with
different images for different pixel
densities here we get the same effect in
Safari which doesn't yet support the
picture element well how did we do that
well it's the same markup but this time
we've made use of the picture fill
polyfill that's a small javascript file
that enables you to use source set and
the other new responsive image elements
and attributes on browsers that don't
yet support them you can find out more
about picture fill from the link below
the video